i can't eat any bread
now i'm scared
hey guys i'm jasmine hey i'm katie and
i'm kelly i don't really know what a
food sensitivity test is my first
thought is that it's a test for food
allergies i've been wanting to take one
for a really long time and i'm super
excited according to every wells website
their food sensitivity test checks your
body's immune response to 108 foods
these food sensitivities could
potentially bring you discomfort stomach
issues fatigue or varying other symptoms
it is not a food allergy test the
results of the test serve as a guide to
help personalize a two-phase elimination
diet this is meant to help remove a lot
of the guesswork in the process so i do
think i have food sensitivities since i
have experimented with diets before i
think i have an intolerance to dairy and
definitely gluten i have always wondered
if i'm sensitive to gluten i've taken it
out before because i have an autoimmune
disease called hashimoto's and i've met
a few people that have said when they've
eliminated gluten their hashimoto's like
went away i think i have a food
sensitivity to soy
milk i am interested to see if i'm
sensitive to dairy i usually tell people
that i'm blessed because 95 of asians
are lactose intolerant i also think i am
sensitive to gluten i've been told many
times that i am i've never gotten a test
for it one time i had really bad back
pain i went to the doctor and i was like
yeah it hurts so bad and she looks at my
arm she's like do you have eczema and i
was like yeah i do she was like you
should cut down on gluten and i was like
but my back hurts i do not want to be
sensitive to cheese
cheese cheese
dairy i'm a little skeptical about this
test but i wonder if it's going to be
like super accurate i'm skeptical
not because i don't believe it but i
like just kind of don't believe it it's
got to be somewhat accurate i don't know
okay
i'm excited let's find out what i can't
eat
okay instructions
step one watch video so i guess i'm
gonna do that first
just watched the video and i think i
know what i need to do drink a large
glass of water warm hands with hot water
for at least one minute shake your hands
by your side for 15 to 20 seconds and do
some jumping jacks to get extra warmed
up time to prick my finger i've never
pricked my finger so we'll see how that
goes
okay he's not that bad now i'm scared
so now i'm just gonna drip my blood into
the circles i have to fill ten circles
with my blood this is my test i'm all
good i'm gonna package this guy up and
mail it back to everly well i'm very
interested to see how this can tell you
your food sensitivities i just got a
text the email from everly will has come
in it says my results are ready so i
guess this is just the moment of truth
it's gonna determine how happy or sad
i'm gonna be i guess for the next week
today is my birthday and i'm really
hoping there's not something on there
that's gonna ruin the day three
two one
and i don't know my email hi jasmine
your food sensitivity comprehensive test
is complete your test showed an igg
reactivity above normal to 46 foods you
have an ig reactive above normal to 49
foods oh my god i don't have any high
reactivity to any foods or moderate you
didn't show high reactivity to any foods
oh i have high
reactivity egg whites egg whites are a
high reactivity moderate reactivity to
seven foods milk
egg white gluten pineapple spelt vanilla
and wheat vanilla cashew cow's milk
eminently i don't even know if i said it
right often called swiss cheese oh i
love swiss cheese blue cheese gluten
goat milk pistachio fries smelt wheat
away i can't eat any bread okay let's
see what my mild anise asparagus which
is something we eat a couple times a
week not pepper black tea
brazil nut cayenne chicken
uh that's like 50 of my diet asparagus
butter butter butter
casein tasting
a major component of milk okay so they
just don't want me having any type of
milk or cheese garlic
so i'm sweating i'm stressed it's
definitely gonna be a week about getting
creative with your foods and it's still
not singing in that i can't have chicken
salmon or turkey throughout the week
that's literally all we eat so i'm gonna
have to get really creative that's a lot
of foods i eat often
i wonder if my autoimmune
disease like had anything to do with
like me
having so many this totally ruined my
birthday i'm so bummed but the good news
is i don't have to start until tomorrow
so let's go good morning it's day one of
cutting out food sensitivities i'm
actually dog sitting today
so i feel like being on a diet and dog
sitting it's just gonna be a lot of work
hey hey come back
i woke up ready to take on this
challenge but first i have to go to the
grocery store because there is nothing
in my house so i'm at the grocery store
right now i'm getting everything i need
but the temptation is real everything
has garlic or ginger or something i'm
just gonna check out all right i'm at
the store and my game plan is to grab as
many veggies as i can to offset all
those lean proteins i can't have i just
finished shopping and i actually was
kind of expensive i got a lot of fruits
and vegetables which was good but all of
that stuff has gotten kind of expensive
and then i bought some things i don't
normally get like almond butter which is
way more expensive than just your
regular old peanut butter i saw coffee i
couldn't get my coffee so i got some tea
i think my husband is gonna be shocked
when i get home and like how many
vegetables i bought all right i just got
back from the store so i got actual pork
sausage and bacon i got some frozen fish
to make quick fish tacos i'm gonna try
out this um plant-based ground beef some
pasta some tomato zucchini for breakfast
i've seen online
sweet potato toast so i'm going to take
a sweet potato cut it into slices and
i'll put that in a 400 degree oven for
about 30 minutes where we'll toast it
and i'm saying toast in quotes i'll put
some almond butter on top of it slices
of bananas a little bit of cinnamon and
a drizzle of honey it actually looks
really good i am kind of forgetting that
it's on sweet potato but i'm not fully
forgetting hmm it's not bad maybe i
should have gone with a more savory
topping for the top because right now
it's just sweet on sweet i'm gonna go
start work and uh chow down on this
sweet potato toast it's a little chewier
than toast all right today is day two of
the challenge i just got to work i'm
about to go in i woke up feeling super
tired just not motivated it is a new day
yesterday was kind of stressful because
i was dog sitting today
i was looking through what i recorded
yesterday and i caught something that
really changed my mindset i just kept
referring to this whole food elimination
process as a diet which like yes i am
changing my diet but telling myself that
i am now entering a diet just puts me in
like a
headspace i am catching that early so
i'm telling myself that this is now not
a diet this is food elimination i
usually start off my morning with a
green juice i'm adding in some kale
green apple some celery i usually add
banana and ginger as well but i have
reactivity to those foods so today i
will be doing strawberries
it is day two i'm having lunch at work
got food from a mediterranean place i
think the fries could be in there like
an oil i'm gonna pretend that i don't
i think i can have granola oil it's not
fried in peanut oil i can't have peanuts
it's not are you sure i don't shh betsy
are you sure they're not fried betsy's
calling me out that's very normal for
fries to be no all right i'm still at
work i just ordered salad i had to make
a few modifications i got avocado
instead of chicken
and i got a cashew based dressing since
i can't have peanuts okay the verge is
in the salad's delicious i don't miss
the chicken at all 10 out of 10. good
morning it is day three i felt the
morning skinnies today
which is shocking to me because i
haven't been eating healthy per se i
just have been cutting out the foods
that i'm showing sensitivities to we'll
say that one thing that i was looking
for was improvement of my skin i'm
breaking out but maybe it's just like
trying to get it out there i'm pretty
much eating leftovers today for dinner
actually me and my boyfriend are gonna
go on a date i am hoping that ordering
out
isn't going to be too complicated i was
able to get popcorn but i can't get my
my best friend over there butter
oh thank you
i just got home from work
stay on my couch and i don't want to
move but i have to make dinner i would
love to order out right now but i'm
realizing that garlic and ginger
and herbs are in like everything i guess
i'll go make dinner
i'm so tired remember when i said i
wasn't gonna make a separate meal for
the kids well this is my dinner for
tonight we had some frozen bean and
cheese burritos in the freezer that my
husband had made salad and i had to make
my own dressing because all the bottled
ones had garlic in it and then to round
it all out of course some portrait chips
all right good morning it is midweek and
i actually woke up this morning feeling
kind of
bloated and crampy i don't think i ate
anything on my sensitivity list i did
eat steak last night which i don't
normally eat red meat so maybe that's
why but since i couldn't have chicken
i tried some steak since i didn't love
that sweet potato toast i'm just gonna
be having an avocado with
hot sauce i'm about halfway through the
elimination diet and to be honest i'm
not feeling amazing i don't feel bad
that i don't feel like how i thought it
would i thought i'd be like jumping for
the moon or something for breakfast
today i'm having the green juice that i
prepped yesterday was good i slept
really well for the first time in a
while no bloating and good sleep all
right it is lunch time and i'm starving
and i'm going to treat myself to a blt
and i'm going to serve it with some
basil mayonnaise to take it up a notch
so the first step is to cook the bacon
and i'm going to do that in a cast iron
skillet over medium heat and as you can
see i cut the slices so not only do they
cook faster but they'll cook more evenly
so now that my bacon is done i have
removed it from my pan i've taken out
some of the bacon drippings and left a
little bit in and then i'm gonna toast
my bread in the rest of it step is to
make some of that basil mayonnaise i was
talking about we're gonna start with a
little bit of mayonnaise juice of half a
lemon all that fresh basil a little
aleppo pepper just to spice things up
and just a splash of water to get
everything going in the blender first
i'm gonna spread a generous
dollop then i'm gonna add some beautiful
tomato slices some lettuce and then the
best part i mean bacon hello let's put
that other slice on oh my god i don't
know about you but i think the messier
sandwich is the better it tastes like
this thing is just dripping i'm filming
again today at work betsy what are we
making
banana banana bread
and i can't eat any of it obviously how
to go for a boba stop i usually get a
milk tea but because i can't have cow's
milk right now i went with a fruit slush
i messed dinner with my husband and kids
and normally i tried to be healthy and
get the turkey burger but tonight i'm
going to treat myself and get the actual
beef burger because it's all i can have
anyways good morning it is time for
another kelly car confessional how i'm
feeling
honestly not that great my acid reflux
is like at an all-time high i'm waking
up super bloated i'm burping it's not
cute i'm not used to eating like red
meats and pork i don't know if my body's
in shock and it's like what are you
doing to me i think maybe i need to be a
little more conscious about just not
eating red meat and pork at this point
in the process i am pretty surprised i
was the only one that was skeptical
about the food sensitivity test after
speaking with katie and kelly the food
elimination process seems to be working
the best for me we are on set today so
we had to
pick our our dish from a menu which
it's a little harder i got a spicy pork
rice bowl and i'm sure that if it's
flavorful it has garlic in it and that
egg roll wrap definitely has gluten in
it some days you just gotta call your
lobsters
today we're all eating together and i'm
cheating i'm having a chicken balmy and
i feel great about it
having work lunch today no regrets
what'd you do i'm vlogging i'm vlogging
kelly are you vlogging don't look at me
i'm cheating
i'm cheating too
i am not cheating i got a steak salad
with everything i can eat on it sauce
sauce it's gonna be delicious for dinner
tonight the kids got boxed mac and
cheese and broccoli and to make it an
adult meal for myself i'm cooking up
some bacon then i'm going to add some
mushrooms saute those up in the bacon
fat throw them some spinach and mix it
all together this looks pretty good i
already took a bite because i couldn't
wait it's so good i just got home from
work and chris he's making me stuffed
peppers
this no garlic thing is driving me
insane i didn't know how hard it would
be to live without garlic and let me
freaking tell ya so for dinner today i'm
having korean beef patties steamed
chinese broccoli topped with some
scallion oil and of course a small bowl
of rice i just added tamari sesame oil
korean chili flakes brown sugar and
mirin mix that all together then pulled
it in some chopped scallions pan-fried
them on a skillet cheers
tastes like korean barbecue i do miss
the garlic though good morning everyone
as you guys know i had that big bowl of
pasta last night and i woke up feeling
pretty bad my stomach is protruding out
i feel bloated it's cramping i just
don't feel great and i know it's because
it was that gluten in the pasta even
though the chest said i could have those
things my body is having adverse
reactions to these foods and i just know
they don't make me feel well and i know
that i shouldn't be eating them i am on
my last night of the elimination diet
and i'm gonna try some red lentil penne
i have never had this pasta before if
it's good that's gonna be pretty
exciting the lentil pasta
has finished cooking
that's actually pretty good it doesn't
have the spring
it's
al dente but then as you chew it kind of
crumbles and breaks up in your mouth
it's good but i'm excited that i get to
start incorporating some of my favorite
foods back in next week
i am reintroducing my food sensitivity
starting with gluten i actually don't
think it'll take up to four days for me
to see a result because i'm about five
bites in and i'm already feeling
gassy cheers
i'm happy whatever happens
this moment remember it i had a lot of
gluten yesterday i had a whole plate of
pasta my eczema started flaring up i was
gassy and i was sweating a lot in my
sleep like i got hot flashes last night
i had salmon for the first time and i
woke up at 4 am in the worst pain i felt
in a really long time my stomach was
cramping it was bloating it almost felt
like i had good poisoning i think it was
just me having a reaction to salmon and
i really do have a food sensitivity but
it really was crazy to see my body react
in that way and feel it in a real
physical way because i really hadn't
felt any different when i was
eliminating now i get it
okay so it's my first day of
reintroducing back some of the foods i'm
gonna start with an egg i cracked an egg
added some salt and pepper here we go
i love eggs so much i'm gonna see how i
feel in two days or if anything happens
between now and two days and we'll see
if eggs was an issue so it's been two
days since i've had an egg and i feel
completely fine i don't know today i've
added back in coffee
and it tastes so good so i'm just gonna
keep adding back in these foods one by
one and just seeing how i react to them
overall i have mixed feelings about
doing this test i think removing a lot
of my carbs and a lot of the sugars i'm
eating and just
kind of the indulgence stuff i've been
having made me feel better it gave me
more energy but i don't think it
pinpointed to having like a food
sensitivity necessarily so overall this
is a great process and it's always a
journey to learn more about your own
body it was an interesting week it was
an interesting challenge and i'm just
glad i got to do it with my friends
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you